it is time to see what's making the
headlines with the broadcaster and
former government Minister Anna subri
and the pr consultant Alex Dean they'll
be with us from now until uh just before
midnight so let us see what's on some of
the front pages of the newspapers for
you now the express leads with the Home
Secretary Zoella bravman's response to
the criticism of the government's
policies on migration from the
broadcaster and former footballer Gary
lineker
this is the front of the Daily Mail the
headline linica's playing the BBC For
Fools
the eye has word of wide-ranging delays
to the long-awaited hs2 High-Speed Rail
Project
the times says the delays in
construction could be as long as two
years
the mirror calls it a huge shambles
the guardian has seen figures suggesting
that at least 500 people died last year
while waiting for delayed ambulances
the Metro covers concerns for the safety
of the zaparisia nuclear power plant in
Ukraine
the telegraph reports on concerns about
sex education lessons in schools which
ofsted says may be too explicit
the financial times reports that two
Russian oligarchs are offloading their
stakes in one of the country's biggest
banks in order to escape Western
sanctions over Ukraine
and the star criticizes Prince Harry for
distancing himself from the royal family
whilst also insisting it's his
children's Birthright to be called
prince and princess
and we are joined tonight by Anna subri
and Alex Dean to take us through the
newspapers welcome to both of you let us
start with the daily mail and we went
through their front page there linnica's
playing the BBC For Fools and Anna what
what do you read into that headline
well look
I mean the mail just couldn't let this
because I think the express was also of
course
um said something like that you've shown
us already Julian their front page and
they've turned lilica quite wrongly into
some Boku figure because he has said
what many millions of people think and
he is entitled to say that and we are
meant to live in a country which
relishes in free speech and I agree with
lilica on a number of things especially
today when he said that this is this
whole route is a distraction from the
real issue which is the aptly named
illegal migration bill that this
government is seeking to put through uh
the commons and the House of Lords and
it it's a terrible bill it's probably
unlawful it's mean it's cruel it's
unworkable and it will not achieve what
the government says it wants to achieve
and actually that's the debate that we
should be having we should be having a
sensible grown-up debate about Asylum
Seekers about refugees about immigration
in general and to be fair to Lyrica who
I I absolutely don't hesitate to say I'm
a huge fan of him I love watching him
when he does much of the day and all the
other sporting events football events
that he commentates on but I also admire
his absolute work much of which people
don't know about for the cause of
refugees and it's it's a considerable
amount of work that he does largely in
private and he's all around a good man
and he's a hero and what penny Morton
said by the way which you did include in
your bulletin was absolutely disgraceful
that doesn't I think make any of the
pages of the any of the front pages
today
Alex what do you think do you agree with
Anna that the headlines with with
lineker and quoting him is is a
distraction taking us away from the
actual issue that that perhaps people
should be discussing
well it's a distraction but it's a
distraction of his making there's
actually two debates here which are
being pushed into one including in
Anna's remarks the first debate is
whether you agree with the substance if
you agree with him about the principle
being debated and the second is whether
a BBC presenter should be saying those
things and you shouldn't actually push
those two together as Anna did I'm
surprised to hear a barrister for whom I
have great respect uh ignoring the rules
because the BBC made it very clear to
linica last year when it disciplined him
over his attacks on a conservative party
and demanded that you know action was
taken over alleged Russians and Nations
the executive complaints unit at the BBC
uh ruled that the guidelines on
impartiality did apply to lineker and
that he had broken them and that he
shouldn't do it again now whatever you
think about the substance of his remarks
it couldn't be plainer that he'd been
warned not to do this as you know one of
the most high profile BBC commentators
and it's most highly paid uh presenter
so whether or not you like his room Mark
seems to me for the second debate about
the principle uh to be beside the point
uh do you think that he should uh resign
should he be sacked
no I I don't go for uh falling for heads
to roll I do think that he is now what I
personally feel sorry for in the
situation is the director General it's
very rare that my heart bleeds for a BBC
apparatchik but actually he's been
putting me extremely difficult position
here because for the reasons that Anna
rightly identifies in some ways lineker
is an asset to the corporation he's a
good presenter on football he was one of
our nation's best players and is
therefore at richly qualified to speak
about sport but the guidelines that the
units responsible for complaints at the
BBC ruled last year he had broken and
ruled that do apply to him made it clear
to him that their presenters are
supposed to avoid party political issues
and to avoid political controversies
well he's gone wading in with both feet
in a style that for a man that never got
a yellow card on the pitch for England
seems to me uh rather out of place uh
and are looking at the express
um their headline as well a bravman
blaster lineker and he also mentioned
Penny Morden in the Commons her attack
on him as well it's it's a bit of a tip
for Tatton public round Now isn't it
and we need someone edifying I mean I
get quite agitated about what penny
Morton said because I just thought it
was really cheap and pathetic because
whatever you think about Gary's views on
on refugees and the illegal migrants
Bill he was one of England's finest
footballers he in fact he you know he
was a he's a world-class footballer he
won a Golden Boot uh and as Alex rightly
says it he never he never got a booking
it was an outstanding example
um to to young football players uh and
just generally and and sorry just just
to come in there
Kelly Warden it was outrageous but what
do you make of the Home Secretary saying
that his uh remarks were flippant and
lazy oh
the woman who went into the Daily Mail
and said that I
were about a
potentially come to our country seeking
Island which is not true that is a false
figure at the very most it's 25 million
and and even then that is a ludicrous
exaggeration and she went on to say it
could be billions of people coming to
our country this is the language from
The Playbook of ukip
that's where that's come from so Mrs
Brotherman really should not be
lecturing anybody about their language
that she of all people and she forgets
she's the Home Secretary one of the
highest officers meet and she should
conduct herself accordingly and actually
stop playing the man and start playing
the actual issues which is this bill
which is a bad Bill it won't work it's
cruel and it's also unlawful Alex
itching to come back there no Julian the
the issue is on debating the substance I
agree with Anna that's where we should
focus but if you want to debate the
substance then the wrong way to start
the debate uh with someone with a high
profile like this is to make comparisons
with 1930s Germany which is exactly what
lineker did anime will have no it's only
the language
Alexis but
um I was making the point in fact not
really accurate Alex no no no of course
it's not he's plainly hinting at the
conservative government which won an 80
seat majority at the last election I
know you don't like the people who know
in government I know you don't like the
fact that it won an election but it did
and it's nothing like at the rise of the
Nazi party and I think it's
extraordinary I'll say that yes if
there's any of course he did well that's
that's one of the comparisons
meant to say no and that's why the
that's why the Jewish Chronicle uh today
has a very powerful piece about you know
shame on you Gary lineker for
trivializing the Holocaust and for
making this kind of comparison and for
you to justify Anna really surprises me
well let me look I it's not language I
would use but I absolutely
defend his right to say head but let's
be factually accurate what he was just
what he was criticizing was the use of
language he then Drew an analogy which I
wouldn't have done with the 1930s and
what was happening in Germany but I do
understand the argument and I do and
there are many people in the Jewish
Community who have backed what he said
some of them eminent Scholars because
there was a lightning of what what hit
them and the Nazis did was they
demonized Jews and you are seeing that
and you have seen it not necessarily by
Leading members of the government but
elsewhere in British Politics the
demonizing of people who are fleeing war
and Terror who are looking for places of
safety and sanctuary and the demonizing
generally of immigrants and it's hugely
concerning and it's not acceptable and
Leonardo absolutely spot on when he can
talks about language I wouldn't have
used his terms but he had damn it I
defend his right to say it I appreciate
you the distinction you make and it's a
reasonable one that you wouldn't you've
used the terms but you've got a great
deal of empathy and you see all manner
of life in the courts you can imagine
how Suella bravaman uh married to a
Jewish man direct descendants of
Holocaust Survivors feels when this kind
of comparison is made to her can't you
no it wasn't doing to her but I don't
have a problem in criticizing soell
about women as I've just done for the
use of her language she has talked about
swarms of immigrants on our show coming
coming over into our country she has
used language as others have done at
this most senior level of government
which is not acceptable and doesn't let
us have a proper grown-up debate and
that is what we need to have we need to
have a fact-based debate Alex we need to
talk about the fact it is 45
000 people it has risen by the way since
apparently we took control of our
borders by leaving the European Union
and the state that we are in is is that
sulac is having to go over to France
tomorrow to talk to macron to try and
repair damaged relations with the French
to try and settle and sort out what
ultimately is a human tragedy people are
so desperate they get into boats to come
to our country for a better life that's
why they come here overwhelmingly and
I'm just going to give Alice the the
last uh quick word do you think as the
Daily Express is suggesting that uh Gary
lineker should be made to say sorry just
very quickly
no I don't I just think he should behave
from now on and I think that confusing
people who are desperate with people who
would prefer to come to this country
preferring to be here rather than being
desperate you're not desperate if you're
coming from France I think really
doesn't serve the debate that Anna wants
to have uh so much very well at all okay
this debate could go uh on and on uh
quite clearly Alex and Anna for the
moment thank you